I'm on a different level of life right
now
cloud9 man Kevin Hart and wife anikó
make their first red carpet appearance
since welcoming their newborn son at the
LA premiere of Kevin's new film
Jumanji welcome to the jungle a couple
opened up to et about adjusting to life
with their new addition at a very high
tell tell me about him what's his
favorite thing to do look at his daddy
not that boy a lot of breasts all right
that's a nice let's just get that out
the way it definitely has a lot of his
mom in them too
he gets the beauty from his mom but he
gets that he gets that dog's side from
his daddy he look good you see like who
want it we won how are the big kids
dealing with having the baby and I are
they just going crazy loving the baby
I think for me that's probably the best
part heaven and Hendrix are so ecstatic
heaven cried when he came home like they
both went to the hospital of course when
he was born but the fact that their
older brothers and sisters my son he's
been a younger brother he's so excited
about I'm the older brother but they're
embracing it
[Music]
you